bueno además de los hechos que
mencionabas el respecto de la cantidad
de periodistas asesinados en el período
que como bien dices han sido
15 en el último semestre de los cuales
10 fueron sólo en la ciudad de
mexico el esto da un promedio si
contamos 6 meses de un periodista
asesinado por semana en l lo que va del
año realmente con una cifra altísima
pero
hay todo un clima de confrontación
contra la prensa
específicamente del presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador en méxico también
del presidente peruano pedro castillo
del presidente del salvador nadie bukele
es una práctica que se viene repitiendo
en distintos en distintas partes del
continente y que va acompañada por otras
acciones que marcan este periodo negro
para el periodismo latinoamericano
un periodo con muchas acciones ominosas
es realmente de muy criticables como es
el acoso judicial y administrativo la
persecución
tengamos en cuenta que en los últimos
seis meses dos medios de comunicación
muy tradicionales como son el nacional
de venezuela y la prensa de nicaragua
fueron confiscados sus instalaciones
ocupadas por las fuerzas militares o
policiales y esto muestra el grado de
ensañamiento que hay de algunos
gobiernos de la región contra el
periodismo independiente realmente con
esa situación que valoramos como crítica
una situación que entendemos exige una
acción coordinada de las organizaciones
que defienden la libertad de prensa a
los derechos humanos y también de
organismos multilaterales para frenar
esta ola de violencia y de confrontación
con el periódico ahora cuáles son las
deficiencias que existen en países como
los que usted menciona a la hora de
abordar la protección a periodistas
con evidentemente los mecanismos de
protección a periodistas no están
funcionando como habían sido planteados
pero insisto además está este discurso
es muy
confrontativo de parte de jefes de
estado de funcionarios que muchas veces
confunden este
accionar que se da muchas veces en las
redes sociales donde se
levanta un poco el tono del discurso
con una acción institucional como
debería ser garantizar el libre
ejercicio de la práctica periodista el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador y
sus funcionarios en lo que va del año
han realizado 71 estigmatizaciones a
periodistas lo cual muestra el
carácter que se le quiere dar a la
relación del gobierno con los
periodistas
realmente es preocupante en un país como
méxico insisto donde en lo que va de
este año han sido asesinados ocho
periodistas
y en el último semestre 10 y 16 y se
computa desde abril del año pasado
cuando realizamos la anterior reunión de
medio año de la sociedad interamericana
de 3